when the office first happened the uk
version and ricky and i sort of got well
known there were lots of plaudits
because it was kind of where did these
guys come from you know they were sort
of new kids on the block and and and we
got a lot of uh sort of plaudits and
then as time went on and we became more
and more familiar then it was like it
seems like it's overrated that show
these guys and then when he went to
america it was like we prefer the
american version you know what i mean
and it's sort of and i think what
happens when you see it with a lot of
people is eventually you so elton john
had that so through the 80s he was kind
of lambasted and then at some point you
become a national treasure if you live
longer yes this is what i'm hoping for
next it's no no you've got you just i
mean trust me i'm trying for that too
but i'm told i need to live to be 150
that's right i need to be the same age
as someone who fought in the civil war
um to be a national treasure but uh
there's this thing that happens you guys
will do two years of a show and then
decide that's enough well that's because
of the economics yes yes no money in
syndication there is no such thing right
so why are you going to make 150
episodes of something it's crazy right
but faulty towers how many faulty towers
are there there are 12
and they're perfect you know the
american style for many many years and i
think it's starting to change i think
netflix and and the way streaming works
now he's trying to change it but
we um if something works in this country
it the mandate was
grind that thing
until it's completely no longer funny
and then do another 10 years
that's right exactly and that's what
that was our system so i was always
looking at your shows and when i say
your i mean uk shows and and thinking
that you were the superior minds and
that you had more integrity than we had
i didn't realize there was just no money
there's no money in it just what's the
point you know you just you burn out
there's only two of you can't afford a
writer's room so it's like why am i
doing this again why am i you know do
something also i think with the case in
the case of the office we did about 14
episodes in total and i think we thought
well we've cracked tv writing it turns
out this is the first thing we've done
and look at it you know we thought yeah
we could just keep repeating this
success forever turns out it's way
harder than you think
the idea of don't quit a hit i think i
would cling on to now with dear life
yeah so it sort of looks like it was a
you know great integrity just a terrible
foolish mistake
and if only we just kept on grinding
that out oh they might have three
bentleys
my former writing partner greg daniels
we got our start together and worked
together for many years and we're still
close friends and so i remember being
worried for him because he told me
the the the british office is done
but i'm going to try and make an
american version and i was worried for
him i didn't think it could be done i
didn't want my
good friend
getting disappointed having a hard time
and um
good god i mean wow that that thing uh
it was brilliantly done and brilliantly
cast but uh god he didn't listen to you
i know well trust me because otherwise i
mean i would just i mean i would i'd be
scrapping around doing stand up in like
pubs
instead of just swarming around with
with celebrity friends i have not seen i
am not i am not kidding i am not kidding
someone could fill a book with so thank
god you didn't listen to conan
because i'm not even kidding there have
been about five or six times in my life
when i've given people advice which was
you know like to mike myers when he he
pitched me
wayne's world first i've talked about
this before he was brand new at saturday
night live and he was like i've got this
thing and it's guys doing cable access
in the basement and i said you know
cable access low rent version of a tv
parody that's kind of been done
yeah and i thought i talked him out of
it and then he went and submitted it to
read through anyway and i was like well
this kid's about to get his comeuppance
oh my god cause i'm the guy who knows it
all well i think smartly the one thing i
i like you you know grew up watching a
lot of tv and there was a number of
attempts to make british shows including
faulty towers into american shows and
they'd often failed and one of the
things which seemed a recurring problem
was the original brits had tried to do
the adaptation
and my advice to ricky i remember
thinking was we should not try and do
this ourselves we don't quite understand
america in its dna yes even though we
think we do because we've grown up
watching american stuff and it needs an
american showrunner to adapt it and we
met with a lot of people but greg was
the one who the only one i think who
seemed to spot that it was really a
romance yeah at the core of it it was a
romantic comedy that also had this funny
boss character yes i think he spotted
that that that romance at the core of it
between jim and pam was what was gonna
keep people people people coming back uh
week to week
to be fair greg is always saying
everything's a wrong match
he just happened to be right in that
meeting
but he and i once had to do a rewrite on
a godzilla versus mothra
creature battle
godzilla hearts mothra yeah yeah he kept
saying it's a it's a romance godzilla
loves ramothra and mothra loves godzilla